let's review what we went over in the
last video and one of y'all actually
commented that it would be a good idea
to draw a timeline so i'll draw a
timeline
short so we're learning about short
selling and in the last example let me
do the timeline where things work out
well for the short seller so let me draw
the stock price of ibm
let me make
this it's let me see let me draw fairly
think a lot okay here we go
so let's say that this is
plus that could be our timeline that's
by day let me draw the stock of ibm it
could look like something like
let me just that's my y-axis
let's say the stock right now is at a
a hundred dollars it's trading someplace
like that
and i you know unless it does that later
right but we're sitting at this point
right here we're sitting at
let's say let's call this day zero
day
zero so what does the short seller do so
let's say the short seller
right now let me see if i could draw his
balance sheet
so right now the short seller he has
assets and liabilities so short seller
short
seller
his assets i won't worry about
collateral requirements and all of that
right now but usually he already has to
have some assets ahead of time for him
to be able to borrow shares but actually
let me give him some
some collateral ahead of time so let's
say that he already has i don't know he
has
sixty dollars in his account
he has sixty dollars of assets on day
zero and then this is the day that he
says you know what i've done my analysis
and i think ibm he doesn't see this part
of the stock price i mean it would be
great if he did then you could short
with conviction but all he sees is the
past right if he did a stock chart he
would just see
let me do switch colors he would just
see this green part right here he
wouldn't see all the stuff that's in the
future but he has a lot of conviction
that ibm's going to go down so what he
does is he borrows a share of ibm on
that day so
here
so then on this day he borrows one share
so he has
let's call that ibm
one
ibm and he also owes one ibm
he owes one ibm
right right when right after you borrow
it before you do anything into it you
have it as an asset and you also owe it
back and if you wanted to unwind the
borrowing of it you could just give it
back but what he does at this point is
he sells this ibm
he sells that share
and he gets
a hundred dollars for it because that
was just the market price that's what
people were willing to trade ibm shares
for at that point in time that's day
zero
then let's say you know ibm reports its
earnings and they're really bad and that
happened on
i don't know probably happened on this
day ibm reports
ibm
reports
and the stock tends to go down down down
people take a long time to realize how
bad the report was and here at this day
once the stock has reached fifty dollars
our short seller says okay that's enough
i don't think the stock's going to drop
a lot more so on day
let's call this day 10 i know 10 days
have gone by
day 10 he decides to cover so going into
day 10 this is his balance sheet let me
redraw it
so going into day 10 what does he have
he has a hundred and sixty dollars
the sixty dollars he had before just you
know
by actually working
and he owes this is his asset and his
liabilities is he owes one share of ibm
to the broker and the broker really owes
it to one of the shareholders of ibm who
happened to be keeping the share with
the broker
and he wants to cover
so what he does is he takes a hundred
dollars
so he takes a hundred dollars
to no no sorry he doesn't take a hundred
dollars now shares of ibm only costs
fifty dollars right
so he takes fifty dollars
to buy a share
to buy one ibm
one ibm
so instead of 160 he now has a hundred
and ten dollars and he has a share of
ibm and then what he does is he takes
this share of ibm and then gives it to
the brokerage to pay off his liability
so then he's done he's left with no
liabilities and just a hundred ten
dollars
of assets so he made fifty dollars so
hopefully that clears up clarifies it up
a little bit in that he sold here and
bought here right it's the reverse of
you know a lot of stock it's almost like
you're acting in reverse time but this
was a very good scenario for the short
seller but he very easily could have
made a blunder let's see let's see what
could have been a blunderous scenario so
let me draw a different stock chart for
ibm
so let me draw the stock
up to the day in question and we said it
was looking something like this
where it was trading right at around 100
and this is the day that our short
seller decides to shorted and this
happens right he essentially borrows a
share of ibm so he has a one ibm share
liability he sells that share and he
collects a hundred dollars
and then let's say ibm reports you know
ibm ibm reports on this day so this is
day zero
day zero now ibm reports and it's
actually great they did way better than
anyone could have expected so then the
ibm shares skyrocket and they go to this
level
and at this point the the and i'll talk
more about short psychology and short
squeezing and all that but maybe here
he's like oh no you know this is just a
temporary blip let me keep holding my
position but then the stock keeps going
up and up and he says oh this is just
temporary it's going to go back down but
at some point his tolerance for pain has
been tapped out and let's say ibm gets
to 150
and he says i can't handle this anymore
and i think you're already noticing a
very negative dynamic or a highly risky
dynamic that occurs with shorts is that
you can lose an arbitrary amount of
money because what's happening now let's
say he wants to cover it right now this
is date this is day 10 in this alternate
universe
so now
what are his assets and his liabilities
going into day 10
his asset we said was he hit 160 because
he had short sold
he had 160 dollars but he owes one share
of ibm one
ibm
for him to unwind this to pay back the
share of ibm what does he have to do
he has to go out into the market and buy
a share of ibm at this higher price at
150 dollars so when he goes out he goes
instead of 160 dollars he has to use 100
so he has 10
and then he uses 150 of that to go buy
150 of 160 to buy a share of ibm
so then he gets a share of ibm
and then he can pay that share back to
the broker and cancel out his position
and he's left with just
so in this scenario when the stock price
rose
by 50 he lost 50 dollars
so he
sold
low
and then he bought high
right
and the really risky thing that maybe is
apparent to you now about short selling
is that his loss could have been
infinite right what if ibm instead of
going to 150 what if it went to 200 then
he would have lost 200 what if it if it
went to 200 he would have he would have
lost dollars if it went to 300 he would
have lost 200 so his loss isn't just the
amount of you know your original short
position it isn't just the 100 or
whatever the original price of ibm was
it can be an infinite amount so it
really can
kill your balance sheet or really make
you broke well when you go on the long
side of things you know if i were to buy
ibm here
let's say you know i'm the guy that
bought this share from the short seller
what's my worst case scenario well i the
worst thing i could happen is that the
share of ibm goes to zero so my loss is
really you know i can just go to zero i
won't end up owing someone you know an
infinite amount of money so short
selling inherently because of this
infinite
you could say downside to the short
seller right they can lose an infinite
amount of money they have to be really
careful about how they make their
positions and how they protect
themselves
from this eventuality and we'll talk a
little bit about things like margin
requirements and things like that in the
future
that essentially makes sure
are the broker's way of make sure uh not
make sure of making sure that the short
seller can actually is good to to buy
back the shares anyway see you in the
next video